to present the award for special effects
a nominee for Best Actor for his
performance and love me or leave me
ladies and gentlemen mr. James Cagney
the winner was special effects they
didn't make this big enough the bridges
of Toco Toco II John Horton
can I ask you a question where are we
why were you so mean two dollars day why
does that upset you sure did
yelling at her throwing her on the floor
hitting her with Joan Crawford yeah but
Doris Day never just a film Jerry I
don't believe everything I see in your
pictures matter of fact I don't believe
anything yellow you had the kind of
parts if I had those parts would be a
whole different thing again this would
you let me play tag in for the captain
and mr. Roberts or both at once I'll
show you what I could do you'd like to
see it would you do it all right who did
it we did it all right Lewis who threw
it over the ship you're gonna stay in on
batter stations until someone confesses
all right Ruthie don't just stand there
seeing melancholy baby
now you gotta tell me the truth what did
you think and when I can't I can't
why say it like that
immediately after station identification
ladies and gentlemen we will take you to
New York
everybody get your snowshoes see Debra
Paget on award-winning matinee theater
live in color tomorrow afternoon